it's time for our scene an unseen
segment where we expose the big cultural
stories of the day well in case of
celebrity injustice late-night host in
Hollywood are melting down over the
Muller news and why is the Pope
withholding his ring from the faithful
joining us with all the details Raymond
Arroyo Fox News contributor a New York
Times bestselling author of the brand
new book will Wilder the amulet of power
Raymond as we saw at the top of the show
the left is just losing their collective
minds over the reporting of this Mullah
report this fizzle done well late night
Land is really imploding and it's not a
pretty scene Laura there's a great
sadness in late night here's Trevor Noah
little disappointing it's a little bit
like coming down the stairs on Christmas
morning you were hoping for a brand new
BMX but instead you find Santa's dead
body we have footage from when he found
out that mala had let him off the hook
when it comes to Donald J Trump's
collusion with Russia you did not
collude
[Applause]
here we're not to say that that is every
liberal in America the woman pounding
the carpet that part was funny that may
be the most truthful moment of the week
the problem is when politics becomes the
center of these comedy shows and the
narrative begins to fall apart well
things turn nasty very fast over ads
Trump TV they will agree that this was a
terrible terrible thing and they want
revenge
if you got rid of all the conspiracy
theorists propagandists and Liars Fox
News would just be a bunch of empty
couches no wait a minute they promoted a
storyline that fell apart but you're the
liar propagandist and conspiracy
theorist I'm not following this at all I
literally have never seen his show but
was he a big hit over across the pond I
know he was a South African as I was
saying that's a big pond he was know
about it's not a hit there either but
now we get here
your fourth stage of grief Lord
depression was all over Plus even
Colbert's face this week but the laughs
were few this weekend we received some
troubling news our president is not a
Russian asset Trump is not working with
the Russians and what the hell is wrong
with them what does it keep saying nice
things about Vladimir Putin it doesn't
doesn't work no when your when your
first obligation is to an agenda and not
laughs it runs aground been funny since
he was trying to like channel O'Reilly
it was great doing the arrives living
vicariously through wanna bust a gut
they don't want to watch him cut
political a bone for Aang's not no fun
now Laura you just reported on the
jussie Smollett story a celebrity
escaping justice because he is a
celebrity well he's not alone there's a
culture of celebrity and justice
emerging video hits social media this
week of rapper cardi B talking about her
past three years ago
[Music]
she's saying she drugged people I got
and robbed them
okay she'd take them to hotel me drugged
man robbed imagine if a a white country
music star went on television oh that's
from three years did i drugged girls
three years I would drugged them and
robbed them oh my gosh the authorities
would be banging on the on the on the I
find her extremely and fascinating
called she's now saying she was just
doing what she had to do to make a
living I mean that's sort of the Mafia
the double standard though is layering
dr. Dre this week he bragged on
Instagram that his daughter gotten to
use USC with no help from him he quickly
had to pull that Instagram posting down
when he was reminded that he donated
seventy million dollars to the skull and
they named a building after several
years ago so there's this double
standard they just keep playing it okay
you have to explain one thought oh I was
confused by this this Vatican video
emerged yes enraged a lot of people this
week it shows Pope Francis greeting
pilgrims that were coming to visit Rome
but he withholds his ring I feel like to
kiss the ring it's kind of cool let's
watch
[Music]
[Music]
he not only pulls it away lor he swats a
few of these poor people I call it the
papal pullback now according to those
close to the Pope I spoke to them this
week at the Vatican he's uncomfortable
with the kissing of the papal ring this
is a medieval holdover Lord it's a way
that Catholics have for centuries shown
their respect not for the Pope but for
the office it's the office dora the
explorer' might say Papa stop swiping
leave the ring out it looks rude it
makes people feel bad and though the
last two popes didn't care for this
either they allowed people to do it
Laura because it's a sign of generosity
and in pie it was a few years ago didn't
he have it oh yeah a few years ago he
indulged others he does it all the time
actually there are other people and look
at this picture here's a guy who was
performing for him he looks very happy
to have him see rings that delighted to
have that and today there was a that's a
very cozy do today there was a nun at
the general audience she kissed his ring
was no problem at all so I think there's
a there's an odd discomfort here for
some but he indulges you is it now it's
your moment go ahead say goodbye to me
in the only way part no don't get out by
the way I'll give you the benediction on
the way oh no by the way I think it's
fine if people want to kiss the ring
they have enough or I can shoot Hirsch
has enough problem I'm gonna miss the
ring virtue signaling the pious its
purchasing thing look at me I'm gonna
it's all that oh it's not a clericalism
okay all right I'm gonna that all right
if you like that segment you can see
more of one just like it on Fox Nation
the Lorne Raymond show you can sign out
for your free trial today at Fox Nation
com